it's Monday Labor Day you [ __ ]
the church what's happening now is
brought to you by Stan's socks listen
that old pack of white gym socks your
mom used to buy it at the grocery store
is now a thing of the past thanks God
you know why cuz stance has changed the
game
they brought art and good design it
would use to be a boring old sock
now when you show a little ankle you're
also showing up what makes you special
whatever you're into they got Star Wars
socks they got Harley Davidson socks
they even got Grateful Dead inspired
socks every football baseball and
basketball team they got that too so
listen right now the church family
stance has a great offer go to Stan's
comm slash Church and you'll get a free
pair of socks what did he purchase the
genie what I just said a free pair of
socks what any purchase thought the fall
off with some nice socks do something
nice for you so take care yourself that
Stan's get a pen s T a and C dot coms
last Church to get your free pair of
socks this offer is only available for
limited time so get your socks today at
Stan's com slash Church because if
they're not Stan's then I just sucks
also the church is brought to you by my
bookie listen let me ask you a question
if you find a hundred aisles on the
street would you pick it up would you
keep walking around like a [ __ ] Mook
of course you'd [ __ ] pick it up so
why do you keep picking winners and not
bet them tell me why that's why you got
to go to my bookie it's fast it's easy
and they pay when you win now I'm gonna
tell you what they're gonna do they're
gonna double your deposit did you
understand let me just said to you
they're gonna double your deposit now
use promo code Church grab a pen CH you
are CH to get 100 percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 who the
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing with
this is my bookie doll AG visit my
bookie doll AG today again grab a [ __ ]
pen my bookie
my be oh okay ie dot AG and don't forget
to use the promo code Church when
creating your account to claim your
bonus listen with my bookie AG you play
you win you get paid and check me out
check my Instagram on Thursday I'll be
dropping a little video for your little
[ __ ]
to teach you how it's done alright so
I'll see you guys Thursday but for right
now go to my bookie dot AG they'll
double your first deposit now that's my
bookie dot AG kick this [ __ ]
mealy [ __ ] tremendous Lenny Kravitz
what's happened what's up man I got a
Lenny Kravitz how's it going man this is
[ __ ] this is not look at this this is
how it should be this is a very nice
little office though me and Bonnie do it
at a dining room table but this is the
real deal like I pulled in there was a
gate this was the real deal I thought I
was going to get my car out of impound
no we tried I scored this office by
mistake this is great we had we had
three other locations that were just a
nightmare and this one has in the big
the first seven months here we had a
hard time and it's been are you not
allowed you know a lot of sleep here or
anything are you know but they want if I
was a single guy and here's a comic yeah
there's a wine shade down the corner
there's the refrigerator
you got Netflix singing notebook that
couch okay that's a bed you could put a
thousand you put a thousand things in
here yeah oh yeah walking yeah for 750 a
month how and if they said you're
sleeper you go no I do my stuff at night
I'm a night man you put the fan on yeah
at night they got air conditioning are
you to bring some men with you kidding
me I might even nice I might even sublet
it this is uh you know when I lived in
Seattle and I was a struggling comic I
lived in an office and the lady the
cleaning lady was knocked on the door
every night and I wouldn't let her in if
that's how they figured out yeah I had a
towel on the floor with a little pillow
and a blankie look like no shower you
joined the gym around the core
I was the healthiest I ever was look I
talked about this on radio or paka and
people throw that's crazy but you go on
Manhattan or in Jersey you rent a
storage space for your furniture you
know throw a couch you know what how the
[ __ ] do they know what you're doing in
your store you go in there in the day
for 3-4 hours take a nap you don't have
to get a hotel in the day see what I'm
saying or it's not little ways to figure
[ __ ] out those stories yeah there are no
windows there's no ventilation you'd go
crazy and so from the daytime so we we
went to Brazil back in it all of us me
Patricia nor all of us and we're there
to meet you know people and I met a girl
there died I started dating right in
Brazil from New York you know they're
all going to the to the to the house
whatever to the place you know $40.00
whatever robes everything so I met this
girl so I start dating her and she said
well you know every now and then I used
to date Lenny Kravitz right when he came
into town whatever so okay now this
guy's playing to guard it so she came to
see me do comedy for the first time I
was at Boston comedy club and she bought
brought three friends from school that
she went to college with now she's never
seen me so I was hosting that night and
I came out of the gate too strong and I
was bombing so bad that I couldn't even
look at her and her friends in the court
you know when you're bought you know I
couldn't even look at him what you was
this ah this had to be
I've been married 15 years ago had to be
18 or 19 years ago maybe 20 years ago
and you know this is girl that day Lenny
Kravitz didn't watch me bomb at Boston
comedy club let's say the thing didn't
really last between us they walked out
you know when they walk down they don't
even look at you either how embarrassed
they can't look in the face the best is
when they come up to you shake your hand
yeah it's gonna be all right
oh my god they get like four of those in
your career yeah and that's the week you
get evicted your girlfriend leaves you
for a Puerto Rican that plays the drum
uncut and then then that's when that one
fan comes up to you and says you'll do
better next time
oh I remember my my first wife and I we
went to Aruba for a week I took her to
Aruba the day we get bash goes I want a
divorce I go well you couldn't have told
me that a week earlier you know what I
mean we went to waste so now I'm
depressed I'm in New York you know we're
talking on the phone and she and next
you know I walk out at a comedy show and
I see my car on the tow truck and I'm
going it can it get any worse and I had
no money back then I had no money you
know now I keep money in case of
emergency everywhere you know I'm saying
just like anxiety medicine I got a
stashed but I had no money and I had to
go into someone and find a comic with
money and get my it is when [ __ ] is
falling apart of my it falls apart apart
apart and when you're doing comedy I
think there's a point in your county
career with things you really do fall
apart and it's a test to see if you'll
quit it's a test from life yeah so I was
at the point where you know we all have
those stories at nights where we put our
hands in our heads and said whatever I
mean you and I are from the same
background you know I have from the
streets you're from a savagery area
lenden know where I feel playing field
camden same difference and Sauk ineptly
yeah you know that's a different
mentality and when I got into comedy
rich I don't know if it was the same for
you this was it yeah knows not what
golly who you when you got into come I
think I was like 28 and what were you
doing before that anything scammin you
know I don't you say I would pound I
mean for years I not years I used to
have a painting business but I you know
I [ __ ] that I'm doing you know blow and
stuff
you know I'm partying and then I did
whatever any type of sales canvas sale
sells out of my car sold cars whatever
you know anything that happened was scam
you know I was it was always asked and
always you know and and and I talk about
this one of my best scams was I would go
to garage sales and I'd find an old set
of golf clubs you know they haven't for
like five dollars there's this beat-up
old golf clubs $5.00 for the set so I
would take buy him then I would go to
the to the deal and go yo man give me a
gram on credit and I'll leave my clubs
as collateral
I don't sell my clubs let me tell my
drug dealers in my town have old garage
sale golf clothes it was a real good
scam you know so I do whatever I could
to get over and whatever it was but then
when I started comedy uh like I knew cuz
I grew up loving comedy you know prior
Murphy I'd listen to old stuff you know
you know Steve Landis Berg Bob Newhart
you name it I just love comedy then I
went to a couple clubs with us do that
he was my deal you know and we went to
some clubs
what were the club as you went to I went
to one in New Jersey called Penny Arcade
and I saw who just passed away Mike
Reynolds I go this is the funniest man
alive I think was him and Mitchell
Walters I'm going this is the funniest
I've ever I go this is great then we
went to catch a rising star a couple
times and I saw you know all these New
York comics and hiram casts on going
this system this guy's great you know
and just the comics that were going on
thirty years ago twenty nine years ago
in New York I go this and then I started
to you know I didn't know what I was
doing in the beginning but I know I got
to do this you know and then and then
maybe a year of whatever gone I started
booking one-nighters in my town
so I could host and then other guys like
me that were booking one-nighters in
like Connecticut Long Island I'll go you
could work my gig if I could work yours
don't we would trade you have some work
we were trade you know and I brought in
guy I had guys at my one-nighter you
know like back then
Dennis wolfburg so bolster Mulrooney I
had I had Richard Jeni opening full form
or Rooney you know and Richard Jeni you
know Mulrooney I go just bring whoever
you want so we you know they get to the
gig and Jenny's like he's got this
attitude right and he goes I don't know
if you know who I am but I'm Richard
Jeni I work as a rising star I go well
you're working here for $60 tonight
right but he and one of the best comics
throughout the 80s and 90s hands down
hands down
and he had an attitude from day one
because he knew we was that good you
know what I mean
and I always got along with you I got
along so did I well yeah I rest his soul
he taught me a lot I learned I worked a
few weeks woman just watch them I was
like whoa whoa did you did you ever see
Dennis wolfburg work no man this guy
clean powerhouse he was up I mean just
kill for same with all those guys back
then
John Mulrooney there was tons him that
this is a slaughter on stage I heard
John Merrow he was a killer Oh killer
crowd were the best crowd worth and you
know real good-looking girls loved dummy
just you just go up there and slay and
it was such in the 80s there was so much
work so many you know in Jersey near
what year did you get into this racket I
let's see I third I guess I've been
doing it 35 years because I got 33 years
clean and I was getting high for two at
least two years in the business you
dirty five years clean no 33 years or
three years clean but I was getting high
when I started for first couple years
okay East too so I've been doing it for
like 35 years but the first two years
was in a blackout but you know so 35
think about it if I had a goddamn job at
a post office I could have retired and
had a pension by now I could be living
work free but as a comic you don't quit
you quit when you're dead you can't quit
this how could you quit what else am I
gonna do you know Bonnie's like let's
move to LA and I'll get a writing job I
go [ __ ] that all night yeah I work in
you know I'm in New York that's my base
I could work in the city and you know
and I go on the road from New York you
still go on the road every week I heard
a lot yeah pretty much you know one you
know I got to keep coming up with new
material you know I'm putting out my six
album it's ready now but I might not
release it to around Christmas but I'll
put it on Sears now but I gotta keep
writing and creating to stay as relevant
as I can you know you know comics that
get caught caught up and [ __ ] they were
doing 10 years ago that's terrible you
know what are you kidding me you know I
can't I can't talk about Nixon I keep
creating so when I go on the road I'm
doing an hour minimum so I could do new
material like New York there's guys in
New York you know they'll bounce around
and do spots and they'll work out there
I work my stuff out on the road because
I'm gonna get paid and work out new
material you know what I'm saying so you
don't go out there in a week where to
New York yeah I'll go to New York one or
two nights at the most but if I'm in
town I'll work the weekend okay see
that's what I do
yeah listen I'm to the point where you
know from 91 to 2004 I was out of seven
actually you know yeah you're are seven
nights a week and then they trimmed out
of the five nights a week
and then it was still animalistic you
know you're not every night and once my
wife had the baby I got a little older I
can't go to the store every night don't
now no more
it just I would be dead because of the
sleep issues I don't sleep well yeah
that wouldn't go to bed till 2:00 and
I'd be wide awake at 6:00
that means my when's I gotta cancel
everything on my agenda because I can't
[ __ ] move
yeah I get that died so I've learned -
now it's Tuesday Thursday and Saturday
if I'm in town I'll try to do those two
shows at the Comedy Store Sardu blue
mainland Thursday yeah originals that's
five spots if I stay home the whole
month that's 20 spots that's not bad
that's not bad
what's ironic plus I'm writing and
you're doing to pass the week you're
doing somebody else's and them being the
most important thing I can be a father
that's listen everything else what
changes you know last night I was
looking at my daughter at the table I
have a podcast with her on Tuesdays
about science I was telling you oh yeah
just we don't date but I'm not but we
just do it the Entertainer so she reads
and I was sitting there going you know
it's a shame I have to go out seven
nights a week you know I have to go out
at night I know if she Percy doesn't
like it she lives with it I explained
that we keep the lights on she doesn't
like it I just know I know her type but
I feel like I'm in the Mafia what would
you do if you were in the Mafia and you
were known as the top hit man on one day
by mistake you got your girlfriend
pregnant and now you got these two kids
and every day when you leave you don't
know you're coming home yeah am I
getting to shoot up today's the day that
they might find the gun from 68 was the
day's the day that I got arrested for
something you know and I feel the same
way now like between you and I I love
going on the road I love it I didn't sir
I loved it when I was getting high oh
yeah when I was getting high
oh my god that was accurate I could stay
clean for three days because I knew I
was going away for four nobody would see
me it was part of the addiction oh my
god yeah it's easy to stay clean on the
Tuesday because was coming Wednesday
yeah they're already waiting for me in
Houston the package is in that doctor
was he saying in Carlito's Way the holes
are dug the sandbags are ready like I'd
be ready to go now I have no addiction
the road I still love doing comedy but I
know I can't go out every weekend
well here's the thing in New York I
could just like this week and I'm in New
York I'm at a club and I'm doing it like
adored yet whatever I'm in it's it's a
showcase club but I'm headlining it so
it'll be instead of three acts doing 20
minutes I do an hour and I'll get
everybody's money you see what I'm
saying right but then you know and if I
wanted to which I didn't I could have
put late spots in at the cellar you know
I could walk out in New York in the city
on a weekend with a thousand or more
dollars or if I'm headlining Gotham then
it's real money you know when you're
headline so but I'll do spots
I won't go crazy if I'm in town on a
weekend unto a couple spots it to Stan
wanted one that to sell like three spots
on a Friday 3:00 on the Saturday am I
going on a Tuesday you know what I mean
but when I go on the road you know and I
won't go for more than a week you know I
don't I always have to come home I have
to come home so I'll do what Thursday
through Saturday or Sunday and then come
home be home Monday Tuesday Wednesday
whatever you know and and if I go out
again and a lot of stuff on the East
Coast also is you know say I'm working
Baltimore or DC you know I'm going in
for Friday Saturday and I'm gonna drive
home Saturday night after the gig for
hours whatever Drive come back from
Boston Connecticut so you know and now
in october/november we got this big tour
we're starting to crease with kids tour
which it's me Bobby Kelly Florentine and
Bennington this is a monster show with
myself I mean eight months we did one
show in pent in Pennsylvania from
beginning to end
it's just murderers row just beginning
to end
it's creeps where kids calm so we got
this tour October November and you know
it's Friday Saturday East Coast we got
Chicago and I Pittsburgh but you know
you're with your friends I'm out doing
comedy with my friends
in a theater no chicken fingers in the
front row no checks being dropped you
know and it's just it you know I'm
looking forward to that you know you
know it's crazy when we first met Tommy
and I didn't get the formula
so my second a two and a half years and
then I got the formula and I put it into
work the formula is get on stage and
right yeah that's the formula that's it
nothing else works just get that agent
right get on stage and right dig in get
into the community get your five friends
everybody books a room you know you
always got something to work with for me
it was the boulder broker you don't get
burnt out what you do when you when
you're first and open micro is you bomb
you bomb beings you're burnt out you
don't even know you burnt down but you
don't have time to burn out you can't
like I've never heard an open mic I said
I'm taking a week off when you're an
open mic yeah yeah you'd never take a
week off that doesn't even exist in your
mind no unless you get hit by a car and
unless your mother's passed away and
even then the third night awake you
better go do some [ __ ] time yeah or
at least such a funerals that yeah yeah
that's what keeps you though it really
does it really people have no idea but
as you get older and other things come
into your life you know for me it was a
child on the podcast yeah okay I knew
that I wanted to put time and effort
into the podcast to get my word out to
put my heart into it to get my you know
it takes time you have to think of ideas
and you have to get gassed and so for me
to be fair to the audience because I
don't want them to ever feel like I'm
just going through the motions yeah yeah
yeah I told CEO last week Theo von
booked a movie congratulations 4pl
uh-huh I've heard of him Pisa the lander
training right now great guy and he was
really concerned about book like he was
very concerned about taking the film
because of canceling and I said
Caroline's comedy on Broadway and
they'll all be there next year this
movie with Chris whatever only comes
once that's number one
number two I could tell your birthday
they've destroyed you they've destroyed
uh-huh and he goes by the way I just I
just cancel braids next week I can't do
it I don't think II can't do it don't
long take it but I was here for years
and well I've been here for 23 years huh
and I watched from Bobby Slayton
so the girl that Wendy Liebman yeah so
all of them go from work in the 52 weeks
to working nothing and I would say first
of Ralphie
let's take ready for example Ralphie was
a dear friend to you and a dear friend
to me I learned so much from Ralphie on
not what to do like it was burned out to
the max yeah yeah and I know it three
hundred pounds well it's like I know
what my knees feel like after a show and
I gotta go back there and put ice on my
knees after two chefs I have put my feet
up and watch Sopranos or whatever the
[ __ ] I watch on Netflix so I can't
imagine what that kid was going through
you know non-stop non-stop yeah you know
he would go to markets I would throw you
were just there but the agents he didn't
know they were just booking them so we'd
learned from the people who come in
front of us we learned you know so for
me the formula that worked so my wife my
daughter the podcast and the road
wouldn't work out is the life I'm living
right now
yeah the summer only without one we come
out well - Kate you know when one today
just today they go oh we got to move
your date in Minneapolis and I would and
I go oh
instead of going oh I won oh that's
great because the week after I'm in
Vegas I go good I get to stay home a
week one week I go well it's me and I
said we'll move it to May or June next
year and plus I don't want to go to
Minneapolis in in the winter I go let's
wait till next year and so it didn't
faze me because I know I'm gonna work it
and you know you're I mean we've done a
million things like you do see back in
the day you go I gotta get two sitcom I
gotta do this do that you know I did
Last Comic Standing and I had a big
opportunity then because it was the
first season I could have moved to LA
and [ __ ] would have happened but I go
I'm not leaving my kids
my daughters were I don't know 12 and 10
men or whatever they were 14 and 12 I go
look if it doesn't happen on the East
Coast it ain't gonna happen but I tell
you what I was here watching my kids
grow up play basketball do you know
whatever so now you just so many things
you create your own projects by and I
have [ __ ] you know we made a movie we
did this [ __ ] roast you know I do all
my own CDs you know what we got our own
projects you know we do special shows at
at you know with Montreal Moontower
skank fest you know would you back
banger you know so you know you could do
your own [ __ ] this year right here this
was not a herd of 15 when we started no
this wasn't heard of you know coming you
got your own studio you're a [ __ ]
radio show that you put together
yourself you see you know what I'm sayin
you know you like and that's why back in
the day I used to respect you know like
Larry the Cable Guy
Dane Cook all these people because they
went around the industry and made [ __ ]
happen on their own and became [ __ ]
multi-millionaire isn't an agent never
made a career no okay
that seems I love when people go outside
in a no agent my life's gonna change
your life's not gonna change now you
sound with the new car she'll still
gotta go in that [ __ ] yeah you still
gotta go in those breakdowns and find
your roles if you want to be an actor
and you know what you're gonna fax your
avails when we used to fax your avails
or email your veil sending press kits oh
my god pressed kids with the [ __ ]
fake article The Washington reporter was
I open for Richard Belzer did I put in
parentheses big deal and I see some now
blank tapes no they were watch no you go
how many times you get made and you see
two thousand tapes with six inches of
dust on bastard this is somewhere in
many
was gone man I'm telling you did I call
any day he's gonna watch my you know
they made movies hysterical how I'm
allowed was troubling but kevin kearney
yes yes yeah yeah sure where is he huh
he's in Vegas I don't know he's I don't
know what he's doing but he lives in
Vegas a pretty nice guy he started in
Philly I know I'm from Philly right i
tormented him for 10 years to get to
catch a ride yeah you know send me a
tape I would send them blank tapes I
like you tape but I gotta find the spot
for you you dirty bubble yeah it took 10
years and when they super caught me and
I walked in the door you know it was
like you were chasing his dream and one
day all the work you put in to get in
nothing awesome a guy just calls me and
says you work in his club and you're
like oh that easy
well I remember work in Pittsburgh I was
at the grouping brothers and I went hung
out with you I go and I left
Michael by gather Joey's in town and I
drove over to your place you were with
the Snider brothers creepy bro yeah at
the funny bone or whatever the fun
that's why I get my first CD at that
Club the one with that [ __ ] ink line
behind it ready to crash through the
building but I I don't know if you
remember this but I came down we were
hanging out that'd be 2005 it was a holy
fun it was easily thousand six yes it
was easily back then you know it was
back in the day but we were both that in
town I don't [ __ ] joeys and I don't
even know how the [ __ ] I knew you back
then how the [ __ ] did I know you or we
knew each other I was a fan of yours you
were the one I was before I started
Tommy I watched you on Sun like a bee or
something black I had you get the only
white guy on something and I always
remembered you I wasn't in to come I was
bad to people doing eight-balls
I was doing time Tommy was naughty this
is 88 yeah 89 90 91 I got a joint with
when I started watching calmly very
quietly very quiet
I wouldn't tell people I was thinking
about it people in jail told me a couple
friends on the car like told me I was
thinking about it so I was watching BT
tapes Joe Torre warming up for many T
Martin Lawrence
I studied the Rodney Dangerfield young
comedians with ectasia at that episode
yeah just like cycled I was at that
taping I went to watch that tou at
Dangerfield which it was the dice one I
think it was either the dice yeah cuz it
was shimma shimma shimma Tetris on I
think maybe even Carol Leifer maybe
Carol Leifer yes Kelly sir the black
dude that made the movie with his credit
cards Oh Robert Robert Townsend yeah I
wish out one of the tapings it was
either that we've already kind of Tommy
there yeah I just want to watch Wow
standing you know in Dangerfield things
and I stood in the hallway and I'm
pretty Kris I knew hissed like I wasn't
like yeah I knew hitch from working with
him not like we didn't call each other
Bowman when we saw each other you know
he liked me and I yeah so yeah but
you're saying so you study that that was
that was some serious [ __ ] comedy
back there no serious those young
comedians still still to this day when I
go on a bombing streak
yeah to get back to basics I will watch
that tape cuz that's the fundamental
tape Kennison at the end Roseanne Barr
yeah Robert Schimmel it has so many
different styles that in one tape he for
me was always the blueprint of comedy
Lenny Clark opened up to one and the
other one was opened up by the guy that
wore the leather jacket that that used
to rap on stage a little bit of white
dude come on now oh he's a mess up Oh
Barry so he's always offends I'm all -
you know Barry some shows of a young kid
that looks like Pepita
Tommy Peter Davidson long he always
shows up a young kid looks like Pete
Davidson that's how I don't say a word
you wouldn't say a word kids crying in
size 18 but the commies do everyone with
the same little broken kid like 18
that's so funny oh my god but that was
the blueprint for me and then my brother
bumped into you my street brother bumped
into you at a benefit that you used to
do and you had a brief conversation with
it and after that we just became friends
I think I did Opie and Anthony and you
were there when they had uh Auto Rican
bodyguard yeah yeah yeah what's wrong
mr. Poe or something miss Kay yeah he's
all around no he's not with all right no
one's around but nobody's yeah how you
do what's a [ __ ] crying [ __ ]
right he was a big time but he's a
little crazy yeah I wanna be a body the
only middle with the body of a posse oh
my god he was a nice guy I met you and I
think we ran until we had an airport and
then one night I just thought it seen
hopefully Julia I started watching you
and Patrice and then the clinker was my
wife's half American Indian if you go to
a house and meet a mother you could tell
their alliance and I'm in the bathroom
washing my face or whatever and I'm like
doing this [ __ ] I'm looking for a towel
and I think we'll watch and I think it
was tough crowd you said something about
when I was in grammar school
Oh homie to go sit in the so I would get
a bottle of gin and go away this bottle
whiskey landed on my wife's American
indeed I don't wanna laugh
we both look at each other with that
look and we watch to that and she goes
that is the best joke I've ever heard in
my life
what's his name and that was just that
you've been your biggest well that's
funny she said divide it up take up the
karate I go over in your mug because
finally somebody made America a joke we
both just went like I was oh [ __ ]
that joke was funny and then thank you
Brogan's told me a joke you said one
night in Caroline's that we can't really
repeat here you threaten him with the
joke he said he goes open with it the
one the one about Robin Givens right he
goes oh my god silence but only one
person laugh is your room Holly Hobbie
loves that [ __ ]
he loves it he loves all of stuff we
should do in Jersey we did a couple of
one-nighters me and him when I was
married to my ex-wife because I remember
me and him working in Seaside New Jersey
because my ex-wife was wouldn't me and
we took a walk to the boardwalk or
whatever this was before he did
Newsradio oh yeah this is way he just
came down from Boston or something and
somehow you know cuz you could tell when
certain people are not right and we were
both not right you know what I'm saying
there's calm like Keith Robinson has the
best [ __ ] theory on comics there's
comics like us that sat in the back of
the bus
and then you get to front of the bus
comics that did our homework and [ __ ]
but the back of the bus comics were
always like [ __ ] ass you know they're
troublemaking kids you know we're back
at the bus comics going grew up doing
comedy ya know and i think of comedy I
learned the gift of calmly on the number
one bus from Jersey City to North Bergen
yeah because at the end of the number
one rap in Jersey City it was a
methadone clinic so after they give me
the bottle of methadone and they give
you a bus pass and 20 junkies would get
on there
the last on 39th Street it was torture
Oh it'sa spitballs and [ __ ] you know we
throw things at him that was a so you
had Oh kids from school took took city
buses y'all took the city by city buses
to school city buses a boulevard Kennedy
Boulevard
oh we had school bus yellow one no I'm
from North Bergen it's the second
Hilly's
city in the country and I would have to
walk both up those hills to County
Boulevard or some of these parents yeah
right up the hill
and then you would catch the number one
bus and it was [ __ ] pure comedy
there's jungle and we'll go get the fix
at 8:30 in the morning and I would have
to be in school and you know 8:45 when I
get on that bus and they'd be nodding
with the Daily News open and I'll never
forget one with the drool from his lip
uh-huh connected to the paper and there
was just a puddle and us just [ __ ]
laughing farted his mouth first off you
made chair that side way yeah they would
sit there by themselves and [ __ ] be
bouncing and his mouth was open that's
like I farted on the chair it was a bank
shot I don't forget that guy we [ __ ]
that's like this is kids going to school
it's like it's almost like you're going
to war you know like we took it just a
school bus and that was the [ __ ] up
kids in the back of the bus and but we
didn't have city buses you know it
wasn't like that you know sitting on the
bus with [ __ ] heroin addicts it's
it's it's great
I guess that's New York City too I mean
these kids are taking city buses
Subway's to school and [ __ ] you know now
kids are so [ __ ] protected you know
so she's got a walk to school now Reina
because if you live less than two miles
you're on your own they took away two
buses
we're 1.9 miles - miles - miles you got
to live
you know or else whatever pay and we
went to pay but nobody else on the block
would pay only me Ambani it was a
thousand bucks to get a private bus suit
and we go oh yeah hey so here's our
thousand dollar check but not enough
people to win so now she's got a walk to
school you know and I get two miles each
way to school
forget it that'll take forever so I'll
get her a bicycle or something I don't
know [ __ ] it or she's on her own but you
drive her well we don't we don't
it doesn't start till next week
September last year she was in middle no
now she's in middle school she was in
fifth grade and they had a bus but now
six and seventh middle school don't have
a bus and she can't walk no two miles
what you in sixth grade last year oh you
weren't in sixth grade
sorry mind your business what's the big
deal no one's gonna question us you
gonna have to give a ride yeah well you
can't walk two miles
no in today's world just no dating
somebody in high school in today's world
how how we were raised and especially
you and I and how protective oh yeah I
wouldn't let my daughter walk to Laurel
Canyon two months
let night daughter walk I wouldn't let
my daughter walk the Colfax and where I
live but I'll tell you what I guess it
was okay for me to run across the street
on Broadway on 89th Street when I was
five
yeah mother told me don't no clue so
like I don't cross the street I've me
and my buddies across the street just to
see if we wouldn't get hit by a car you
understand so like I'm a hypocrite
because well when my wife came home a
couple of weeks ago and told me the camp
was taking her to the beach I'm sorry
about this in the beginning yes I did
I go I wouldn't aside Don really I go
yeah you better go to the beach ruined
they gonna burn out loud so for three
Wednesday's in a row I kept it together
but from 11:00 to 2:00 my heart was in
my hand yeah you taking my daughter if
something happened you understand I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill you
I'm gonna go on blasting first so you
better pay good guy went to the camp
I pulled the counselor over I tried to
give her a half a yard to let her know
take this yard you're responsible
that's something matters for this kid
I'm gonna break your [ __ ] skull you
understand they took him to the Museum
in Long Beach which I was petrified yeah
meanwhile was okay for me for the school
to take me to the well they took in New
York and New Jersey your first trip was
the Statue of Liberty yeah I would have
and I still remember being in North
Jersey and I'm taking us to Betsy Ross's
house in Philadelphia and The Nutcracker
Suite and whatever you know and no my
mom didn't complain she signed away well
we stood well one one I took her to the
beach on the other day to Santa Monica
right I remember and I [ __ ] first of
all I didn't want to go in the ward or
side wards Eames you could tell from the
East Coast so I'm sitting on the beach
with [ __ ] jeans and a [ __ ] t-shirt
but I had to walk down to the water to
watch her and she's going all the way to
[ __ ] out I'm having a [ __ ] anxiety
attack I'm gonna come you're out there
you know I don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ]
going I don't want to [ __ ] my wallet up
in my phone going in to save you move
the [ __ ] in and I'm having anxiety
attacks and I couldn't even imagine
somebody else and I'm not there and she
said you know what I'm saying I couldn't
imagine that well thank god she's a
goofball my daughter she's a seashell
[Laughter]
thank God thank God she likes the water
a little bit but thank God you know but
I'm a hypocrite because you know I
wouldn't let him she came to me today
and said I'm gonna walk to the corner on
Colfax is a little liquor store there
right so candy I would absolutely tell
her now which 60 yards yeah but at 6:00
I don't know how many times I made the
joint I used to walk to school in from
kindergarten yeah till we took the bus I
mean I would kindergarten first grade
and I was walking you know whatever half
owned to school back then that everybody
walked to school back then we didn't
have a butt and I didn't have a bus till
fifth
grade because it was way far and junior
high school high school I don't know cuz
I didn't really go that much I just I
just want to sell weed I want you to
live a school huh did you quit nice man
I was in 10th grade I was in English
class ago can I go to the bathroom he
gave me a pass and I never came back
really but I would just go to school for
15 or whatever at lunch periods and I
hang out in all three lunch periods with
different crews and I saw some smoke up
there or get high hanging by the heater
where it was warm and then you know
[ __ ] go home everybody ugv know I got
what you got wasn't I had one before I
had to get one before you go to prison
Oh for your point levels go up so you
don't they don't put you in the shitty
prison so I wouldn't got my GED that's
what you got to do to get an extra point
- uh - or take it off yeah high school
diploma
when did you so you don't tell me two
years when you realize the drugs were
getting in the way of everything
Jordan oh well it had nothing to do it
kinda I go either I'm gonna I'm gonna
die or end up in jail now your wife had
already disappeared no no I didn't even
know my wife my kids had never see me I
was single thank you sir now read the
first time you were single I was sobbing
uh clean clean oh really okay okay oh
yeah that's what ended the whole thing
no no she never seen me I none of them
none of my kids ever seen me huh god
bless I didn't hear 28 26 so I got 33
years no I was i I was gonna die I go to
jail because you know I was just out of
my [ __ ] mind
it didn't matter it didn't matter you
know how to get it where to get it
you know you know you what we you walk
into places up in 158th and Amsterdam
you know do told and you know pieces to
your head didn't phase me didn't I do
this on stage - it's true
like I put myself in positions where I
could have easily been shot robbed
whatever no fear and now at my age and
this is I said I'm scared I'm gonna slip
in the shower I'm scared to go
yeah it's skin if you think about it you
know I look I've come back when my car's
you know years ago out to train station
you see the window broken are shifting
took my radio they broken a car but I go
how am I gonna get mad I I did the same
you know I'm now I'm the victim
you know what I mean I can always go
back so yeah I got clean because I had
to I would be dead and you know rehab
yeah for five day detox 28-day rehab and
then the program carried you through
since day one well ya know the desire to
stay to stay clean I mean I shot an hour
special at an a convention you know it's
[ __ ] weren't you know they're trying
to sell it now my management this
[ __ ] thing is it's [ __ ] really
cool it's a masterpiece
I'll show you the begin after we're done
this I'll just show you the minute of it
but you know it's it's a shot it's never
been done
never have they allow cameras in a
convention not a meeting it's a big
convention obviously I don't show the
audience but I'm doing comedy and talk
doing recovery calm you know [ __ ] I
can't do on a club because they don't
get it you know they just don't get it
and and this special is so [ __ ] cool
it's you know so yeah meetings and and
12-step programs and and a lot of my
friends are all in recovery you know
what I mean I mean I hang with a crew
that were all [ __ ] up when we were
younger
you know did you know Jimmy when you was
getting I who know or no no Florentino
no no no I didn't know any of them no
and and that's the thing about comedy
too and I think we're all decent comics
but we hung around with so many good
comics you had to be good like Patrice
Keith Billy Burke Norton Bobby Kelly you
know when you're surrounded by great
good comics don't call you out on [ __ ]
we used to sit at the cell and do hack
court and if somebody had a hack
we bring it up and do hack court and
tree so we hung around and a lot of the
guys I hang a while around with or don't
get high
they don't drink you know and and and I
was working with some comic recently
he's talking about how he's getting high
on stage and and I walked over there if
I go come on
are you serious peel your face from
[ __ ] doing meth all nighter you know
steal your cell your mom's card and talk
to me about getting [ __ ] high you
know I don't want to hear about your
bottom where you [ __ ] passed out on
the front lawn you know talk to me when
you're [ __ ] when everything's gone
you know what I mean everything
spiritually motion emotionally you know
financially bankrupt completely
everything's gone you got nothing
sleeping on your mom's floor that's what
I did or wherever you could sleep you
know and now I look like a you know
should I put kids through college I got
a town house I get you know what I mean
like that's why I couldn't get high man
do you think that sometime does it occur
to you that maybe you had a couple
different lives cuz you're a little
older than I am
yeah two years or something yeah 56 yeah
and I sit here don't think of recovery
stories I think of where I was 12 years
about 13 years like I think about 2007 a
lot how I was broken I was broken bridge
I was doing yeah I was getting heroin
mailed out in Jersey right after 9/11
they were getting in Newark $3 bags of
heroin and I would do a little line
every Monday and I wouldn't do coke the
rest of the week and for some right and
do coconut like a month or something I
have to call 20/20 and tell him I know
how to get rid of cocaine addiction I
mean I was crazy I know how to be
cocaine addiction devil lining every
Monday I thought I was like Lois past
door I don't have invented something
that's this is how crazy I was it the
writer's strike
The Longest Yard coming out everybody
got a call Tracy Morgan got a
corporatist walk Chris Rock got a TV
show
the the the mother black guy Terry Crews
got on Chris Rock show everybody got a
show
Goldberg got a race car show everybody
gotta love except me so I'm the dog
throughout the whole movie they're
telling me it so I have I wish I was
broken emotionally financially I mean
when I quit my wife had to take that
alone for me to pay my debt so I was
probably down 14 G's and child support I
was down Mike the final number was 636 a
month for six years I had to pay alone
back six hundred and thirty six dollars
a month
Wow but I still owed the attorneys money
from my divorce and ninety one you know
do you know I just about a year ago paid
one of my old drug dealers one of the
few that really deserved that
that really put up with a lot of money
yeah but I really put through hell like
I would hide money on them and tell them
I left of money and then I think got
ripped off I don't know what you're
talking about
and of sleeping with his ex-wife I mean
I put him to the margin I put him
through hell but he you know what he
came to me like a man when they need us
amen
dad talk to you about some just I have a
kid with her and I really want to
reconcile with her as a man would you
stop messing around with it just for we
could and I shook his hand I never talk
to that girl again
because he was a man I always respected
them I was about three years ago he him
you know hey I he doing congratulations
I said bro send me your address I didn't
forget about the 1600 I never forgot him
$1,600 he would bring me a gram and I'd
give him a hundred you go what about
what about what smell
come on no no I can't do it I'd have to
talk him into an afterthought for two
years I put this guy through I put all
my dealers meow I put all my dealers
truck I had one dealer would leave me
coke and his motorcycle and I wasn't his
garage I have to open up the garage and
go onto the seat and I wouldn't leave
the $50.00 either he would call me a
next day what happened to the money I
left it there my [ __ ] roommate that
[ __ ] of
I remember going to his house one night
I talked to him like these are the
stories that when you tell them and you
have these to the end and you think back
at them and they're funny but at the
same time they're so sad and tragic what
you were doing and the people around you
were doing this guy was a black dude who
I loved yeah I still talk to him I still
talk to my ex drug dealer because I put
him through so much abuse especially
this guy so I knew this guy was a boozer
when he was boozing I wait - hey get
boot and I go to his house his girl from
ago he passed out what are we doing I go
he left me something in his pocket and I
was going his pocket and take whatever
it was when it was an eight ball or a
half a gram I take it he more gives me
an ounce of coke in his pocket in his
pocket and I do me and he caught me next
day what would you take out of my pocket
I don't know maybe a grandma give me the
16 tomorrow I did that to him for years
he would come to my house and nights and
go man my girlfriend threw me out and I
mean one time he came up with a bag of
fried fish and my cat attacked him he
gave him the fish when he was passed I
would take all the coke out of his
pocket he would wake up and go man I
could have sworn I had 26 grams I woke
up with 21 you know people don't like
you ever think that your story's a [ __ ]
you didn't go who was that rich boss
well like this dude I knew came up from
Florida my mom was away for the weekend
so he came up in Florida saying my house
he brought an ounce of some of the best
I mean this joy was amazing what you was
this straight towards my end it was 33
years ago whatever 34 years ago 35 so 35
has thrown one dirty is 89 on a problem
I'm 87 it was still good it was he
brought it from Florida he came up and
he fell asleep on the couch
man you don't fall asleep leaving at her
I ain't likely I had I cut it I took
some I took like an eighth out put an
eighth in of cut you couldn't tell you
know the dudes
and I'm still he's sleeping just don't
wake up you know this girl I met this
girl Boston I was working Boston
Massachusetts
so I go I'm not gonna spend my money I'm
not gonna spend it come Friday Saturday
night you know I'm doing all these in
one night and I had like 600 bucks and
back then I was a lot on my six or $700
I met this waitress make sure you know
from Worcester Mass I drove back to New
York City
spent all my money got a hotel then I
had to drive her back I was home I had
to drive back and still do Sunday night
up in Boston and Nick's right with no
money drive them back driving back to
Boston my nose started believe and I'm
holding the shirt right and like my
closest up there in a paper bag you know
and then I had to drive back home again
now I'm broke so I go well this girl
this girl said to me her sister wants an
ounce I go well I'll do the I'll rip her
off easily I mean how hard would that be
so we're setting it up but then I ended
up in rehab right because I would have
ripped her off we ended up in rehab I
ended up in rehab
two years later I'm working down in
Florida at the comic strip and that girl
who I would she was in the audience with
her boyfriend who was a monster if I
would have ripped her off what are you
kidding me they would have found me they
would they would have found me so but
that was my bottom was like weeks later
I ended up a rehab after driving from
Boston then back and then back up I had
a fun night don't get me wrong it was a
fun night but why did you go all the way
back to New York because we couldn't
find out nothing Boston I didn't know
anybody up there
you've told stories like that like going
from like where is it San Diego but I
went to Ontario one hour 10 minutes
Ontario I get to my hotel room
I set the sleep apnea machine up I'm
ready to go to bed no way what are you
crazy
dr. holiday went together Jibo and all
the way back to Ontario to do what I
missed radio the NFL banned me for two
years this had to be 2006 they'd been
through years The Improv crazy and then
I got a yeah and then I got a call and I
started to bring improv the dirty show
but that's fine I believed in me yeah
you said though I had different lives
yeah but it's all different lives in one
life because I wouldn't be where I'm at
now without those long without right out
of the same way okay I wouldn't have
raised my kids the way I raised them
without having parents that weren't the
best parents you know what I mean just
selfish not my mom my mom was you know
she had a raise three kids but then you
get you know someone like you know
you're your dad's coming to visit you
you haven't seen them a week so you're
standing by the window there's daddy
no some detectives jump out of the
bushes and lock them up so who you mad
at your mom for setting them up and
using you or your dad for not paying
child support you know what I mean
so they're both [ __ ] up so I said when
my kids I'm gonna be the exact opposite
you know I remember one time throwing my
father I need a picture of me growing up
and he had like two I got hundreds
thousands of my kids you know what I
mean so just they did I guess the best
they could with the tools they had but I
said I'm gonna do better with my kids
you see what I'm saying I'm gonna do
whatever it takes to raise my kids to be
decent normal nice kids
you know this kids a genius over here
that's cuz of Bonnie she's a genius
it's crazy what she knows straight A's I
never got an A she gets straight A's
the [ __ ] I look at I go what's an a look
like you know but you know look at all
that [ __ ] in the past all that stuff is
you are where you're supposed to be when
you're there and it's all from
everything I did in my past not only
made me a semi better person it made me
a better comic look at all the [ __ ]
we know from life you know you see you
know we have so much to go to dig back
on to write material about and and to
talk about because we've lived life
we've lived it you know I pay you know
you get you get a 20 year old comic
they're 22 23 they're funny they got
good jokes but it it's not coming from
here it's coming from the head not to
heart when you see a comic that's
talking like you watch you like I listen
to you on the radio
knowing that [ __ ] is real that's not me
I said he didn't make that up you know
for some roundtable that [ __ ] is real
you see what I'm saying and that's all
curse of the life we've led and I'm not
saying what Tommy's better than another
you could watch Brian Regan and laugh
your ass off all night long
or you could listen to Stanhope going
that's some real [ __ ] right there that's
something you know I mean I maybe I'm
talking in circles and I'm great no no
no it's a way you know what I'm saying
though right you know your audience to
go what the [ __ ] she talking about
I'm just saying there's different types
of comedy and comedians I'm drawn to the
real ones Patrice you know what I mean
guys like you Colin Rogen's real and you
know all of them there's a certain breed
but then also I love just guys that are
doing stuff that's funny as [ __ ] you
know that you know you walk out what he
said I don't know but he was funny
John Mulaney yeah some like when he's a
very polished for a guy like Mia that's
who I intended to be why I got into
comedy
yeah but I'm too [ __ ] filthy I was a
junkie yeah I don't have the heart of
John Mulaney to see our dad it's I
understand what you know do you have any
shame in your past uh my time if you
have any shame I mean you look ya know I
mean look what the [ __ ] it's the past
there's nothing I could do yeah I try to
make as much amends to people as I could
and my main amends was I got clean and
my parents my mom died knowing I was
clean
my dad's 91 he knows unclean so my main
amends is to myself people I've made
amends to hey I'm sorry this or that
look I owe dudes money paint stores is
an anima the [ __ ] you know if I really
hurt somebody I would say it but now I
know if I hurt somebody I'll say I'm
sorry or make amends right away you know
what I'm saying but my pants what the
[ __ ] it is what it is you know I've
tried to make amends with as many people
as I could
did you feel that there were some people
that it's better left not to yes I have
like two or three people that I'd really
like to call and reach out and say how I
feel but it wouldn't change anything
yeah it would just make me feel worse
than I already feel about the situation
so I ignore it you know I think if
you're deep down sorry for [ __ ] you did
and you're not doing it again you know
what I mean
you're what else can you do plus you're
setting an example for your kid
you know you're not that person you were
so your kids are gonna grow you know
like I said my kids grow a pretty
[ __ ] stable so they cuz they didn't
see me out there they didn't see me
doing the crazy [ __ ] I I think the one
thing I feel bad for and I did say I'm
sorry you know what I put my mom through
you know I had drug dealers that I owe
money to towards her car you know I wait
my own money
next you know the next one her cars on
fire burnt you know why you know so and
not only could I call the dealer I go
look not only you're not getting your
money we're getting a new car from
insurance but I thought you know then
another time I was in New York somebody
hit her car smashed it so I go do that
dude yo man give me a hundred and just
go and I took two hundred then I said to
my mom
yeah to call his partner someone here so
I did do put her through a lot of [ __ ]
and I did apologize to her that sorry
for what I put you through when she was
in the hospital I went in even said I
love you which it was it's always been
hard for me to say that I could say it
to my kids easily easily but it's hard
for me to say it to just anybody I gave
it to my wife to my kids but you know so
I said I love you even though she would
had Alzheimer's I don't know what was
going on in her head and I apologized
for what I put her through but she saw
that through the years of me staying
sober too and giving her grandchildren
and whatever so I don't know I mean
listen I'm still [ __ ] up you made your
peace with it yeah I'm still [ __ ] up
looking to who buying jewelry and
sneakers and 62 years old and weren't
about Nikes what the [ __ ] is relevant
you've you've earned you've seen the
other side and now you're here you know
I tell you what bothers me about comedy
that comedians get hot and people come
seeing but there's a handful of comics
that just because they're not hot
anymore people won't come out and see
them and they're really the best comics
working the circuit today I've always
felt that you are that guy I've always
felt that you're one of the top three
guys working to that you're and I learn
a lot from you
when I won't bonnie was telling me that
your obsessive walking in your health
and your fitness and because you know
how important it is guys like that first
of all we we transferred our addiction
oh yeah we transferred our addiction
yeah we live by transferring of
addiction you know I am NOT a hypocrite
or anything I I did my time I went to NA
meetings and stuff like that
I got cleaned by myself I made the
promise and Cubitt all the man's promise
I made a problem I got clean my making a
promise to a [ __ ] cat a cat was that
night and I said have you saved this cat
I'll never get high again the first four
days I was kicking the cat I might die
you [ __ ]
and the cat live and I still have the
cat get out that just cat still alive
and he was playing game a kiss and
coughs I mean I just that's great I just
said if I don't drop star on me again
I'll quit no go ahead so I just said out
how quit and it was the toughest 30 days
of my life and I did it and I think
about two years and I got on my hands
and knees and I apologized to my mother
my mother died when I was 16 but for all
I mean you know I couldn't even when I
would get high I would think about her
when I would get to that surf spot of
the night you know when that that
dopamine's something goes well when you
think about your life when you look
inside and you're like I'm the ugliest
purse in the world this is why I'm doing
this I deserve to die that's that point
that where I
I apologize to my mother the best that I
could for those 28 years of abuse that I
did my stall and yeah ruin relationships
but again like you named dick I could do
it's part of who the [ __ ] I am today
it's why I work so hard today it's why I
made my amends you know I went to prison
because I didn't claim responsibility of
my life that's the biggest thing don't
you take responsibility in my world I'm
the one that killed the Kennedys ask me
who killed the Kennedys Joe Diaz who
killed Jimmy Hoffa jug beer
bomb last night Joe Diaz I did it all
who killed those kids in Iowa last week
I did it because it makes my life easier
when you learn to claim when you learn
to say I'm [ __ ] up yeah you know and
that's what those are all the parts of
recovery learning to say you [ __ ] up
learning to apologize you know yeah
learning to rich boss if you want me to
I think and 56th I think the last trees
have been comfortable in my own skin
I've come to terms with what I've done
until there every time I do a show and
somebody comes up to you and says your
podcast help me I'm like what the [ __ ]
you talk I love when people come up and
want to take a picture of me
to myself if they know 15 years ago I
try to pickpocket wife is taking a
picture her purse is open yeah years ago
I would have been taking that purse
right out of there
putting it in my pant pocket and then
saying telling people I gotta go to the
bathroom yeah taking the cash out
picking up this toilet lid throwing the
wallet in there looking around and
finally about an hour later we found it
in the men's bathroom it must have been
the Busboys he can send him the bill for
the picture oh my god you know that that
was the reality of who I was that was a
reality of who I was that white powder
made me Rob
whoever when it was well it was post
time when it was 8 o'clock at night and
that anxiety you get that that drug
anxiety it runs through your body that
makes you blackout until you get the
product in your hand well my last year
my last year I would black out until I
had the product in my head oh my one of
my lowest points I was sitting in a bar
in New York it's called the film Center
40 cent drafts you know I'm already
tapped out I'm down so I'm sitting there
in this girl girl goes can I buy you a
drink so I said okay let's go but you
got to walk up and get it and she hand
me $20 and I walk to the bar and ran out
of the door and just ran with her $20
and went and bought two more you know
vials but that was the lowest point of
my life probably to do something like
that you know now I wouldn't do it for
less than a hundred you know it makes
you just do [ __ ] that you you wouldn't
do that as a person as a person so but
look at the comedy I love doing comedy
like people go well you know it's so
funny like when they talk about acting
and me and Bonnie just did a little part
in Pete Davidson's new movie come you
know that but you know they go why are
you doing this or I go on the comic
everything else is a bonus both it's a
problem Sunday I love doing god I love
doing what I [ __ ] do I just got it
you know you just got to try to stay
relevant so you could still get people
in the door and you know you west coast
comics are killing it me and Bobby were
talking about this the other day you
[ __ ] are killing it out here
you know on the road and around the
country it's so weird how things shift
you know during the owene days opening
and guarding he's gone
we will you're killing the kill women
killing it I never thought of that
six days and now [ __ ] and Bobby said
this on the 5 because dumb Anthony had
to go take a picture in Times Square of
some blank chicken [ __ ] up you know and
and and we were I mean killing it on
tour with them and doing it on a virus
and and now the West Coast comics are
killing it you know I mean it's it it's
just it and it's everybody we like to
[ __ ] Burt you know you I don't know
Tom I did radio twice with Tom and I had
a good time with the right guy I don't
know I'm like you know on our podcast
we'll [ __ ] around you know going after
door saying look we're playing antennas
you know and and we go they stole our
idea even though they did at first you
know what [ __ ] you know but the nicest
guys I don't know him like that no I
know bird you Joe I kind of met
what's-his-name a couple times
sorry well no I know already well I did
I kidding me [ __ ] artis you know so
that could you know what I mean
and Theo I I've met deal a couple times
nice guy and every time I see him I tone
how much I like his [ __ ] on Sirius radio
I feel like a little groupie I go that's
just funny that they put on Sirius radio
well it's the same [ __ ] bit I hear
every time but I still funny so you got
it and and we go you know what [ __ ]
these West Coast [ __ ] we're
putting a tour together decreasing kids
we're back we got to do something you
know and and and there's room for
everybody this like this it's right now
I'm just happy I'm happy that you're
doing well I'm happy your wife is doing
yeah
I'm happy that we're all healthy you
know I miss Ralphie yeah I'm sure you
miss Patrice with all your heart you
know every Saturday I think about
Ralphie I just called the twins I just
called the it's not about the smash
brothers yesterday just cuz I went to
lift uh-huh I went to lift and then I
went to cry out of fries and while I was
in crying I go this is jino route she
should have been coming home on Sunday
yeah or slide out sleeping eating dinner
with his family working out Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and leaving on
Thursday since he didn't do it now I
have to do it for well you know I mean
addiction is powerful whether it's food
gambling drug whatever it is spending
it's it's powerful it may be in the last
six months I could finally listen to
Patricia's comedy on the right if I'm in
the car and Patrice comes on I can
listen to it I the second I heard his
voice I would turn it off I couldn't
listen to it I'd get too depressed you
know because we were you know I remember
one night me and Patrice I was taking
him home to Jersey City and we're
walking I had to go in this house go to
the bathroom and we'll walk down the
street and I and I go I don't have a
[ __ ] thing going on in this career
and he goes man I don't have [ __ ]
happening no agent no manager me there I
go we got nothing and then we just
started cracking up and laughing I just
kept walking and I remember that and
latest we had nothing to work in Boston
comedy club you know [ __ ] gigs on the
road and then you know two years later
things are happening but you know and
other people had a bond with Patrice but
me and Patrice were close you know I
mean I'm closer with Norah obviously he
was the best man in my wedding but we
were all tight I mean me Noren Patrice
Keith you know name little keV came into
the crew but me and Patrice you know we
would talk on the phone sometimes two
hours at a time at night just talk you
know I'd call him about this or he
called me about that he was
trashing me on radio one day beat me
down so bad talking about I had a little
porch and he was driving an Escalade or
whatever and he beat me down saying I'm
selfish I have a Porsche and he killed
me and I drove home furious and then
like two days later I looked up the
price of his car anew and a place of my
car new and I text him I go my car new
is better than your car new across the
moor he called me up cracking up going
you're still thinking about it
still he goes I forgot about it when I
walked out a radio see so we had so much
and and I couldn't listen to him on the
read I couldn't listen without getting
so depressed I was
I wasn't closing my brother throughout
my life when he passed away and I wasn't
as depressed I was the most oppressed
one Patrice even probably more than my
mom you know what I mean cuz when you're
not close to somebody good friends and
Billy and Bobby were close what you know
what I mean
he was just such a and now I listened to
his stuff on the way it's so [ __ ]
funny put that elephant in the room odd
that's a name really oh yeah once every
six months so [ __ ] good as I [ __ ]
laughed my ass law sometimes the tear
comes to my office I think of what a
great [ __ ] talent he was he is he was
one of the headliners I went to see one
year I one of the headline I I was
losing my desire for comedy I wasn't
doing spots at the store and I said [ __ ]
it I'm gonna go watch every headliner at
The Improv that yeah and I think Geraldo
yeah [ __ ] I said liner I saw the idea
but a tight second was up at alonso was
just more polished and he was yeah not
anymore joke driven right but Theresa
was buck wild like me yeah by you [ __ ]
in it
well Patrice wondering but she sure had
some clever [ __ ] about Danny started
getting into the whole relationship
stuff but it was real clever stuff it
wasn't hacky Malfi it was just really
misogynistic but it was brilliant you
know what I mean it's just brilliant
stuff and I said to some Bennington's I
was doing the unmanned or [ __ ] around
with man I go you know Patrice I was
sitting down on stage before Patrice on
a stool he stole that from me
I go was Cosby and me okay and then
Patrice took it and [ __ ] Bennington
[ __ ] killed me because I was his
[ __ ] and they just the Internet to
Twitter and and it was just so [ __ ]
they just beat me down saying that but
three I said but we stole the sitting
down from me his funeral I mean the
numbers he [ __ ] it was packed packed
and everybody went on and talked of
course I had mine I closed it out Kevin
Hart went on Carlin before me you know
we're gonna use me last of course
I walked up at his funeral I go before I
get started I just want to say after the
memorial I'll be out front selling my
CDs but everybody who spoke at you know
what's funny and Sierra tango be
laugh-in him and tears and you know he
was just such a for he would be the best
comic right now my god hands down hands
down would be the best kind of embrace
you know said that a couple years ago
bill burr said yeah the main back there
doing the spot and he goes that if bill
if he was alive today
yeah he [ __ ] about that's crazy
he was nothing he was so controversial
and he was so honest you know he always
took the right side he didn't always go
you know with it would you know if do if
it was a black issue he didn't always go
with cuz he was black he goes well you
know what if this is if you're wrong you
know this is the deal you know what I
mean so whatever he was just a lot of
great memories a lot of good memories
standing late at night out in front of
Boston comedy club me him keith Norton
just [ __ ] trashing each other all
night me and Patrice were walking home
walking from the cellar and we stopping
at Boston and these guys
around it or mine but Ben Bailey and and
DC Benny would me and Patrice walk down
we beat him down real quick verbally
walked in beat him down and walked out
right and they think they beat us down
like better and and and DC Benny think
they beat me and Patrice down like oh
not a million [ __ ] years we came in
we knocked you out left and we kept
going and we didn't walk down the street
laughs and it was so much fun back then
and it's so much fun you know man this
uh this comedy journey is [ __ ] so
you've been doing it now how many years
company 35 what's the number one advice
you have for comics if you had to give
anybody advice to just keep writing and
get on stage wherever the [ __ ] you can I
don't give a [ __ ] if it's a knife fight
if you can do ten minutes there do it
because you're gonna learn something
just get on and and I see here's what I
unto in study comedy know the history
know what the [ __ ] that's what I did I
really studied yeah really I study I
used to go watch comics and headliners
and and and ask questions just like if
you're going to the gym or your work if
you're you know taking any type of box
in a martial art you're asking questions
when I used to go to you know when I
first started going to gym I would ask
how do you do this who do what you just
ask questions and watch and learn
no the [ __ ] the history of what you're
doing you that's just to me maybe it's a
whole new scene out there with the
internet and YouTube but you know you
can you could go to some comics now and
bring up Tennyson they probably don't
even know who the [ __ ] he is or Hicks
they know who's that know the history
know you know who [ __ ] open these
doors you know what I'm saying people
will come up to us and go tough crowd is
the reason I started comedy a lot of
people say that but you know I I don't
know why I said that it just maybe for
some narcissistic ego [ __ ] reason but
I knew I studied common I studied it
also I studied it I'd listen to it I
watched it you know I you know I chewed
it I [ __ ] swallow like
I did everything I did everything I had
I knew that for you to do this you got
absorb you sand off house like I watch
the guy that cut watermelons I wish I
had one of my favorite I'm not ashamed
to say that it's the puppet guy which
wanting him live you'll die with the one
that died was brilliant with his crack
addiction and the phone booth on
Tuesdays that he had the puppet that the
one from New York that one that that his
dick had a little notch on and she could
slow coke out of it kicked oh and I
don't wanna show ya holy SH I used to
work with him all the time yeah that's
brilliant stuff did the clean one what's
the cleanup Jeff Dunham Jeff Dunham if
you go watch Jeff Dunham unless you're a
hater yeah you'll laugh a little ha I
haven't seen Karen top in years but but
he's the best product if you're gonna do
props he's the best right you know how
many [ __ ] prom packs are left so it's
true comedy
study it when does this creepy creepy
kids tour if you want to take its creeps
with kids calm starts in October and
it's creeps with a cake right yeah
creeps creeps we kids calm Robert Kelly
jim Florentine another guy that nobody
really talks about is that [ __ ]
Robert Kelly I don't know people know
that he's a force to be reckoned with of
force
are you kidding on four I saw a special
that looks like some Indian Asian kid
shot at the Tommy sour yeah Tommy
essential picked it up they play it late
night
I was rolling he went on a [ __ ] tab
twenty minutes about fat he said I was
[ __ ] dying another guy that's a
powerhouse of a comic then nobody talks
about well now he just got that Netflix
the generates DeGeneres right so it's
him him it's a good liar oh yeah miss
Pat
miss Pat o donnell rawlings Adrian who's
funny I don't know how to say less
animal lose and there's one more I can't
take it off Bobby is a [ __ ]
monster Bobby is a [ __ ] power I knows
he will have no idea
that's why kills me at this yeah you got
your Sebastian you got your furs
you got your Joe Rogan's you got your
Dave Chappelle's I can name you ten
other killers that you'll pay $10 for
and go what the [ __ ] was dad Bobby
Kelley's one of those [ __ ] tornadoes
would that distort the crease for kids
Florentines been at it for another third
of it Bennington is so [ __ ] good
wanted besides the tour when the best
one they the best radio hosts in the
business and and and me who semi-funny
at times you're gonna and we're keeping
it torture like $25 a ticket to see four
[ __ ] headliners so creeps with kids
calm and if you want to see the best
roast ever go to Voss roast calm it's
the best roast out there Voss roast calm
it was murderers row crease for kids
calm voice Rose calm if you want to quit
getting high you can do it there's a wet
you can do it just whatever you can do
it you don't have to live that life I'm
not here to preach I'm just saying you
can live whatever life you want you can
live whatever life you want I got off
the coke and everything they're still
smoking my pot to let me know I'm that
dirty person
yeah I can told you that without pot I
gotta be honest yeah I'm home before I
did two bong hits it really doesn't do
nothing
yeah only and I need it in the morning
when I wake well that's it coffee I like
a little bong it just to let me know I'm
normal but besides that like it's it's
the last teddy bear that I have well I
already got rid of the pacifier I got
rid of everything well I'm not listen
you put a crap table in front of me
forget it oh really okay yeah listen I'm
not I'm looking I'm not getting high
okay but I'm not [ __ ] person I play
lottery numbers go through my head to
every day you know I'm playing [ __ ]
numbers whatever state I predict
for you also me too you know what's good
beer with CBD you doing these no no I
won't [ __ ] around no it doesn't have THC
in it like this there's no I know okay
but I heard as I know you're very
concerned about you how yeah I don't
[ __ ] with that
I heard there's someone told me they
just did a study that I don't know I
just look I'm in physical every day I
wake up in some kind of physical pain
but what the [ __ ] you know if they on me
too if I take something then in in a
month that ain't gonna work I'm gonna
have to double it in two months I ain't
gonna work next you know I'm melting
down tylenols and shooting them yeah you
know what I mean so I just got to deal
with [ __ ] I've got a workout I go to cry
out and I had a drink tart cherry juice
what the [ __ ] is that you go to GNC my
tart cherry yeah it reduces inflammation
it takes away some Pam 56 and you know
sometimes I gonna do jitter and I'm like
why should I be sore for 3 days 3 to 56
[ __ ] suck and you weighed 300 pounds
that's why that's why you [ __ ] saw he
said you know I lift heavy toys ahead I
go really heavy like squats and pull-ups
pump convention all the compound [ __ ]
for over 50 this is the [ __ ] that keeps
you strong on stage but bro and that's
day I can't walk they say I go to
acupuncture every other week I double it
up I'm gonna I should try that for I had
a puncture every other week and then
every other week tapa so we gonna go for
a 40-hour massage I work him one time
felt good but I didn't expect to go to
massage they put gym shorts on meet me
downstairs over here right over here $40
listen I'm gonna walk I'm [ __ ] I'm 62
okay I go to the gym four or five times
a week you literally just that Bobby
said you know and I was doing a lot of
steps Ross um I took it easy
I walked yes sir I play golf I walk six
miles up and down hills I my legs were
cramping like [ __ ] are you a picker
and everything she says you on my phone
I got just step things on my phone I'll
lift you know I'll punch the bag at home
I got a bag in my basement I'll punch
the bag you know I'll try to eat okay I
don't you know I've tried on but I wake
up you know I got back pain
and [ __ ] and whatever it's just get oh
yeah here's the thing when I was I I
said this on before the pygar like when
I look back I saw Elton John in 1977 he
was at the garden with Kiki Dee they
were on tour don't break him on it
yep and I was probably on quaaludes acid
at least three or four whatever the [ __ ]
I was thrown in my system I saw him on
the farewell tour I was on tylenol and
anxiety medicine what the [ __ ] age does
to you
Rogan last night I go I live on Cuban
quality and Aleve that's what keeps me
together
I told Lee Lee goes where you going I
gotta go take a [ __ ] I don't have the
triple expressin took a tremendous [ __ ]
and took a shouting card cherry so I do
this at 8 o'clock
I just comes in and it happened before
you go to bed to just slides out in the
morning I have the pictures to prove it
you want to promote where you at this
wish creeps with kids calm
voici calm if you want to see a great
roast I'm telling no murderer man I told
your wife was German and you and your
wife have a podcast oh yeah my wife
hates me yeah I don't I don't see it all
right thank you for having me thank you
I'm glad that we got to hook up and do
this man you're very much man listen
don't forget next week Friday 13th I'm
in Dallas there's like eight tickets
left and then the next day the 14th I'm
in San Antonio in the Aztec at the Aztec
Dean I don't know what's left and then
on the 27th of September I'm at the
Chicago theater all right I want to
thank rich vos I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] savages for
always listening listen that's it it's
Labor Day [ __ ] in this Labor Day it's
official
you got [ __ ] whatever three and a
half months to get your [ __ ] life
together we're down now we're ready to
attack we're in attack mode so it's over
whatever the [ __ ] you would think
it's over with the thinking now you're
gonna pull into full effect by anyway
who gives a [ __ ] about that
listen the church is brought to you by
Stan's socks like I told you earlier
they brought art and good design to it
used to be a boring old sock that old
white gym socks that your mom used to
buy it at the grocery store remember
with the sneakers if your sneaker slip
and slide
take them back to the panty pride that's
done those things are dare to pass
Stan's has changed the game now when you
show a little ankle you're also showing
off what makes you special what you're
into they got it they got Star Wars
socks they got harley-davidson cycling
through Grateful Dead inspired socks
they got they got NFL football baseball
basketball they got that too it's not
just cool colors and patterns Stan's has
everything from running socks to ankle
socks to hiking socks premium socks you
can wear in your office plus Stan's
socks are incredibly comfortable I am on
my feet a lot I'll tell you that much
and some of the most supportive socks
I've owned are the Stan's socks they are
[ __ ] solid that's why Stan's socks
are the official sock of Major League
Baseball and they give back their socks
for Heroes programs cents socks to
deployed military personnel all over the
world I got the icon socks myself and
for my wife and I got paid for Lee over
here I just haven't given it to them yet
a nice blue pair of socks they say good
vibes on them I just want to remind them
what's important in life
long story short Stan's makes a great
gift all right so right now today Labor
Day the church family Stan's has a great
offer for you go to Stan's comm slash
Church go to Stan's dot-com slash Church
and you'll get a free pair of socks on
with any purchase that Stan's comm slash
Church grab a pen sta n c e dot com
slashed Church to get your free pair of
socks the offer is only available for a
limited time so go to Stan's calm today
and get the party started
if they're not Stan's that just sucks
all right the church is also brought to
you by
my bookie Dodd AG listen if you're
trying to bet on the NFL baseball MMA
whatever my bookies got it what's his
weekend what do you got you got the
beginning of NFL you got khabib against
4ei I'm telling you if you're gonna make
D this this is the weekend to do it I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them if they weren't the best do the
smart thing if you're gonna bet this
football season college football season
college but whatever the [ __ ] you gonna
do go to my bookie did you know you can
bet on games after kickoff ah by the
second half it looks like your betters
gonna lose you can always take the other
side if you're the kind of guy that
likes to bet a little and win a lot you
try a parlay if all your picks come true
boom you multiply your winnings and no
matter how you bet the NFL season is the
best time of the year
double your first deposit now by using
promo code Church to get a hundred
percent bonus on your initial deposit up
to a thousand dollars who the [ __ ] you
think it you think Uncle Joe is gonna
show up here with some [ __ ] loop
LaRue hell no I show up with my bookie
Dodd AG today that's my bookie grab a
pen my bo o ki e dot AG and don't forget
to use promo code Church when creating
your account to claim your bonus listen
with my bookie you play you win you get
paid it's that easy now don't forget
like I thought in the beginning
check the Instagram add flavors where
other one I don't know what the [ __ ] of
this I'll be dropping a video with the
pics and teach you how to make bets
every Thursday for a few weeks just to
help you out you people a little lost I
don't know what to do with you but
anyway go to my bookie doll AG go to
stance calm right now Andy you know I
love you guys have a great holiday today
I hope you eat some burgers you eat some
fries you burp you get your dicks like
you get your little monkey eating and
it's the start of the fall we're going
straight through the [ __ ] Christmas
Eve you understand me I don't give a
[ __ ] what you're thinking listen have a
great week we'll see you Wednesday
morning stay black take this
[ __ ] mealy